this program is brought to you by emory
university it makes an exciting
developmental phase right now we did get
a grant through the office of university
and community partnerships it's a
program throughout emory university that
helps university they connect it to the
community and build partnerships where
there's a mutual beneficial relationship
we had a grant from them which is
allowed us to develop its curriculum
further right now we have a one month
elective and it's open to medical
students residents PA students nursing
students public health student and so
it's a great multidisciplinary group who
come together and really want to focus
more on these issues in addition to that
we're putting parts of this curriculum
within the required curriculum so for
the medical students right now the third
year students are getting a half day of
these types of topics taught by us
through their ambulatory curriculum
where they're doing outpatient medicine
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University